so riot games you know the publisher of
league of legends is suing a relatively
small time eSports or called riot squad
for use of the word riot what anything
is riot squad doesn't even have a league
of Legends team so what the [ __ ] is
actually going on here
[Music]
alright so to find folks at Riot Games
have filed a lawsuit in the Central
District of California suing riot squad
for essentially trademark infringement
rather than paraphrasing the point let
me just quote the lawsuit directly here
quote riot squad eSports LLC riot squad
has unfairly and unlawfully adopted and
exploited a riot brand name in
connection with its marketing
advertising and promotion it references
the Lanham Act a 1946 law that basically
outlines how and when trademark holders
are entitled to federal legal judgment
several pages later the lawsuit goes
even harder saying quote in adopting and
using the riot squad name particularly
in connection with the eSports industry
with which riot has become synonymous
riot squad knew of riots brand and the
goodwill associated therein and intended
to appropriate and trade off that brand
and its goodwill riot squad
intentionally used the riot marks to
confuse and mislead consumers into
believing that its eSports organization
either is riots or is associated with
affiliated with or sponsored by riot and
quote now it might be worth noting at
this juncture that riot squad doesn't
actually have a league of Legends team
they do pub GE they do Rainbow six and
they also have a csgo team with a few
familiar names on the roster at least if
you follow na csgo Dondi just barely
avoids him in fact he turns around and
finds the frag this looks like it will
go the way of riot squad in fact it will
now a pretty big chunk of the middle of
this lawsuit is explaining basically how
much of a big deal League of Legends is
and outlines what seems to be every
single use of the word and the mark riot
in league of legends the complaint then
tries to claim that Riot Games and in
fact just the word riot when it comes to
eSport
has developed quote an enormous amount
of goodwill among consumers and members
of the public who associate riots
anonymously not only with mall but with
eSports as a whole and quote the lawsuit
also takes aim at riot squads merch in
which they often drop the squad and just
print riot in big letters basically if
you're not on the same page yet this
lawsuit is trying to claim that riot
squad the unaffiliated eSports
organization is trying to ride off the
coattails and make a buck off of the
name of Riot Games the publisher of
league of legends to hit it home even
farther the lawsuit says quote
defendants wrongful conduct has
permitted or will permit them to make
substantial sales and profits on the
strengths of riots marketing advertising
sales and consumer recognition and quote
so what are they actually suing for well
obviously one of the things they want is
for riot squad to stop using the word
riot they also want riot squad to quote
deliver up for destruction all products
that allegedly infringed on riots
trademark
[Music]
they also want all applicable legal fees
tons of punitive damages and three times
the profits that riot squad is made
which no offense
I can't imagine has been that much no
really if you don't believe me quote
riot seeks an accounting of defendants
profits and request that the court grant
riot three times that amount
end quote now when it comes to the core
contention of this lawsuit that riot
squad has sort of intentionally
misleading members of the public and
riding off the coattails of the Riot
Games name my first reaction is that it
didn't pass a common-sense test I mean
look I haven't passed the bar or
anything and no disrespect to riot squad
but who is confusing this minor eSports
team with the publisher of League of
Legends I mean just look at the riot
squad logo it's so edgy I guess maybe it
looks like or thought a little like
imagine if you were a million dollar
investor you're at the top of a
skyscraper in your boardroom you're
chief of marketing walks in and he's
like yo should we invest in riot squad
and you're like is that like Riot Games
the publisher of League of Legends and
Runner of the franchise League of
Legends leagues he's like I don't know
who cares probably not gonna happen
right however all that being said that
doesn't mean that this action by riot
isn't totally understandable from a
legal perspective after all let's be
honest here
there's a lot about trademark law in the
u.s. that doesn't pass at least my
personal common sense test I spoke with
our resident lawyer here at the score
who you can probably see behind me right
now actually and he clued me into the
fact that sometimes companies need to
challenge or be litigious about marks
that are similar to theirs in their own
space to set a precedent that way if
like a year from now a eSports company
comes up called games riot or something
and Riot Games can sue them and point to
a history of protecting their brand they
can say hey remember a year ago with
riot squad but we wouldn't let them into
the space with their name were certainly
not letting you it could actually make a
difference in a legal fight you know
Riot Games actually is very active
in the old Patent and Trademark Office
of the United States they have a ton of
either approved or pending trademarks
multiple pages of them in fact
trademarks like wrote or riot riot Forge
legends of runeterra true damage riot
tabletop cache riot and NER Joe a pura
Tech lease in the tribunal quiet right
now how would you guys like to hear some
approved or pending trademarks in the
United States Patent and Trademark
Office but uses the word riot but isn't
riot games you would great
how about Hollywood riot library riot
fruit Wyatt
beer riot Sun City riot riot kayaks riot
films riot box riots reptiles ceramic
riot mark riot snack riot rebel riot
riot cheek be try it
wink and riot Pizza riot that's a good
one run riot cash riot riot swag hell
yeah